hey guys I'm back from New York I am
picking up Maddy hi Maddy say hi you're
very handsome you know that we're gonna
go get some food I'm at Jenna's right
now picking up the pup and then we're
gonna go fly the drone a little bit more
it's basically all I wanted to do and I
realized that I didn't even fly it in
the launch of that video that I posted
yesterday I thought we make up for it
today you ready to come and get it no no
are you ready
it's very hot
actually can I get a t-shirt give a
Glock t-shirt by any chance how about
this gray one okay we're all changed
let's go how do I fly the drone it's so
easy let's go let's go let's go so I'm
gonna be on wheels today I'm just gonna
be rolling around on the Segway I'm
gonna see if I can do all the things
that you guys do while on my wheels what
me okay I'm gonna get back on the wheels
I was just faster they try to be so safe
like we're not gonna take you to
dangerous temperatures speeds no
temperature speed now close this for you
yeah do you thing else done around here
that I can help you up
where's good up
it's almost like I'm a drone know
nothing about bipedalism baby
[Music]
oh hi where should we go down
[Music]
it's coming they'll fly some drones will
one drill a single drone 10 even us by
github yo I have not gonna be fun
I'm still so tired like this week last
week it's a non-stop filming and editing
images Wow wild time and this week oh my
gosh our parents are coming next week
ya know yeah like five days four days
three days I'm not sure oh my gosh thank
this year where are you oblique appear
on your yet
we both got the shot thanks for meeting
my drum video problem do I get a drone
yeah you can pre-order Sunday okay get
back to New York
thank you a bull Hubble look at this
these are solid this blast is so good
I'm not sure it's a passionfruit mint
something it wasn't no I like it's just
a surprise like wow I can't believe
you're outside all right I've been Evan
I've learned that as my ways I've been
trying to be more social oh yeah judging
by this pan of yours you've seen the
outside crazy girl cheez-its come in on
the way
oh well okay what's up go to that sign
say oh no Maddie honey I just peed on a
sign I'm on wheels today
god it's so fast now that I turn off the
speed restriction look I'm cruising I
think we might have found our first
obstacle can you see first cuz I don't
know if I can go all over this good cuz
I can't go over that I'm on wheels today
we made it to the top he's right over
there
okay Mandy what you doin honey huh
Maddie saying hi to everyone
oh good hi honey good boy good boy come
on Maddie go say hi make friends honey
Matta
set it off recalibrate to the hadn't
recalibrated into New York so
calibrate every time you fly just
[Music]
nothing is untrue
and their wheels because this is a
wheels day this is day so I'm gonna try
some of the intelligent features like
[Music]
[Music]
so that
bigger
[Music]
I forgot that I was gonna let you fly it
honestly I was here angled the dog was
enough I landed it and then I looked
around and couldn't find you so I did
like a loop on the Segway boxing watch
the queen of the boxing Allen products
or sell this is pretty exciting so
should we go should we open it up for
what go to youtube.com forward slash
nadeshot if you want to see it or
there's one on the scene already yeah I
did it whoa they want your life a few
things we're not in boxing just one no
this is uh this is unboxing cool things
number two I thought they're supposed to
do the opposite of that this is like it
okay I'm excited for this I'm actually I
want to see you on boxing scuf
controller this was your video what
would you do Jesus Christ
no but the I have sorry I didn't even
source of electricity ago but it's good
because don't need an extra cable like
this use for wouldn't it be more of the
extra isn't it the same thing
essentially it is but when I'm traveling
I don't like to have to bring an extra
cord
so sometimes forget this please bring
this I just bring this in a place
because this has a nightstand mode so
you can just put this right here and
when it is sitting up like that it'll
well this is just wow wow yeah
oh you're like cheating you're on the
ground no tougher right now to be honest
with you
get there get there by the way nice job
hi I haven't done this in a minute so
nice nine ten you got it Matt you got it
yeah buddy
wow that was really going down all the
way that's good I was on the price look
at that nice little doe a little baby
miss you know baby and look at you with
your Apple watch - looking so so ripped
I feel so ready deep thoughts there you
go
bye Matt I think she'll let me be a part
of your unboxing whoa that's great hi
guys I'm leaks for watching him at home
end of this video I think today was
supposed to be a cooking video but I
don't have one prepared for you so I am
very very sorry but what is happening is
there's gonna be a YouTube live gaming
show I'll put a link in the description
there's also a playlist so you can see
that we're doing that tomorrow tomorrow
is the first episode Matt of the YouTube
gaming show yes yeah I'm super excited
it's gonna be really really fun so we
will see you guys live tomorrow or
actually today so I'll see you then
[Music]
now what's so remarkable about these
images so you can fit it in almost any
bag just put it in your bag